[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj che ci siano tornati su
8 dead the glass caption ci avrei mai
sperato ritornarci questa roba prima
inter agazio chiffon dlc gratuito che
sarebbero corti i corpi di otto dead è
uscito questa settimana qui praticamente
dovrebbero essere dei corti
ce lo dice il nome dovrebbe essere parla
col cameriere non mi ricordo neanche
come ci si muove gli sto cazzo di gioco
figurati se devo ok mi ricordo un cazzo
perfette al mi chiedevo no non la porta
è questa eccoci siamo grandi si no
cosa sta calmo cameri dove camerin non
riescono anche a muovermi giorno salve
signor i quali non me la vostra
presentazione un borbottio che cosa ci
chiusa al vento non vedo nessuno sa se
potrei vedere meglio se ricevessi una
piccola mancia sai dovete la piccola
mancia lo sai hai mai provato il colpo
del tentacolo questo è il colpo alle
tentacolo va bene se ti porto questo
come mancia c'è tipo uno smoking questo
pezzo ecco ti piace perfetto attacco in
faccia possiamo sederci adesso mi
spiegate come faccio a trovare del
denaro degli islamici sono stimati ce
l'ho fatta ho trovato delle mazzette
alla l'ascolta mitia dotta micara io ti
amo da morire ma potresti non prestarmi
il tentacolo tipo leghisti razzisti buon
uomo e si sta facendo amicizia col
attaccapanni sono cose da napoli che
stanno accendere che altri stessa cic
cazzo fai peccati sti cazzo di sole ecco
abbiamo un tavolo per due grazie di
cuore a vico via dalla scorta devo
rimorchiare questa donzello quindi non
per infarcito di merda grazie a prima io
amore prima io poi le signore premi ten
stai ferma stai fair
ecco profeta brutta zoccolo allora
avvicinati ato6 chi abusa le braccia per
sederti perché questa non ti sembra una
posizione comoda passo tipo no no no non
mi sta officiando un coltello nel
deretano chiara e sto soltanto cercando
di sede no scusami tesoro perfetto
ragazzi sono se vento cerchia di bere
dell'acqua cerchioni bere dell'acqua per
quello che devo capire un attimo i tuoi
gusti allora io ho mancato il tavolo
cosa ha portato del vino
sai far colpire vi chiama vuoi fare cin
cin facciamo il sinking dai botti sicuro
di se possiamo fare cc ragazzi fare il
cin cin
tra un po lì poi un essere umano è una
cosa che non si vede tutti i giorni ma
io lo so fare [ __ ] ascolta che ha
un attimo che devo prepararmi aspetta
carena queste sono sono le mie tecniche
di degustazione vino prima di fare cin
cin 6 tranquilla se se ho fatto
ce lo fa in chi è stato bruttissimo
cerca di bere del sud non basta vi prego
mi spiegate come sia possibile
io sono un uomo che ci sa fare con le
donne da clima lavata in bagno attimino
cara è uno scherzo a questo vado ad
allenarmi mi scusi ragazzi non so
scusate lo scorso 6 pazienza la tipo
dove c'è scritto pc ecco perfetto
qualcuno mi spiega il senso di st perché
non aveva mai giocato subito sta roba è
bellissimo cazzo di massa manica
ok ora la rata ragazzi che sono tipo
sporchissimo di succo di frutta in
faccia morgan
eccolo lì mi è saltato lavand incazzo
già fatta cioè fatta lei lavandino lo
riparerà qualcuno un giorno io io non
sono stato e non ho niente in mano come
prova è stato veramente bello
cazzo mi scusi se si toglie anche dai
[ __ ] sto rimorchiando una donna poi
in cucina ventrone ripariamo a no vabbè
vado in cucina scusatemi
io devo cucinare mentre quelli puliscono
il casino che ho fatto io ho fantastico
da vai cuciniamo i ragazzi chiamiamo
chef ramsey e vediamo se non sono in
grado di fare bella figura
scusate un attimo secondo me
l'ingrediente giusto ecco qua eccolo qui
perfetto riempì la caraffa con del sub
sì però stai caldo ce la posso fare
eccolo qui eccolo qui perfetto eccola lì
per ciocca gatto dentro sta roba
perfetto riempire a caraffa celoro
riempita mica pd così riempito bicchiere
quello di scarlett perfetto ragazzi ho
finito è stata l'esperienza più bella di
tutta la mia vita però adesso devo
tornare dalla mia donna perché sto
rovesciando un po di succo da probabile
capotale scusa scusa per don pardo è lei
è molto sexy
ho portato del buon vino di casa ha
fatto da persone in gamba
lo verso anche a te ferma un attimo
vacca scusami il tesoro non volevo si è
fatta giocate eccoci perfetto non è un
compito di cameriere ma io sono un
gentleman tesoro io faccio di tutto sì
esattamente così ci si sia detto hai
preso non sono troppo sexy tesoro perché
hai fatto una sedia a caso
6 ributto come un pesce facciamo
conversazione un borbottio di poche
parole certo una scuola i trucchi far
rompere il ghiaccio quanto libro
preferito un borbottio per rifiutarsi
qualcosa ma dopo vuoi un po di pan di
pane imburrato tesoro io sono un amante
del pane imburrato porca [ __ ]
ma se mangiamo un coltello ce l'ho fatta
credo di avere imburrato il park
perfetto lobo ai più fino occupati anche
degli altri clienti prima di proseguire
lato romantica cenetta cosa io devo
procura insieme che cazzo fate voi dal
mattino alla sera fa mi capirà perché si
è messi sta posizione bruttissima prendi
l'ordine della coppia buongiorno messi e
arrivò subito finalmente arrivata la
pizza se la pizza voi ecco prendo arrivo
subito messi a segno un po nuovo per
servire i tavoli ma è uguale sì ma io
non sono un cazzo di cameriere anche
solo perché ho la cravatta non vuol dire
che sono un cameriere casson eccomi qua
ci sono subito aggiungere del pepe
subito web ecco per voi ecco anche una
buona candela che non fa mai male
ancora un po di pepe si signora subito
ecco un po anche nei capelli perché
ottimo anche come shampoo signore e
signori perfetto perfetto ragazzi direi
che ci direi che ci siamo buonissimo
questo coso delizioso non sei l'unico
quando i segreti ho fatto delle indagini
nevada mangia l'insalata una per chi ha
in quanto vanno mangiate legarsi cazzo
ecco perché uno alla volta così ce la
faremo prima o poi eccolo lì un
assaggino tesoro corso ragazzo vediamo
come te la cavi
vi prego basta pulire i tavoli li
pulisce tua madre i tavoli amiche dopo
li ascoltami tesoro arrivo devo fare
l'ultima cosa e poi ho finito dopo lire
i tavoli scusatemi amici miei devo
soltanto ecco così si può dire che i
tavoli [ __ ] un fenomeno vero
artista vari certo osservato ed imparate
è però che stai parlando affari jazz io
sono io che pulisca i tavoli come dio
comanda nota temi e state parlando con
un esperto perché mi sto portando un
tavolo dietro aggiungi del sale al tuo
pesce guarda io ci aggiungerei una sedia
però non so se la stessa cosa usa la
forchetta per mangiare il pesce ci siamo
ragazzi è una cosa complicata ma ci
stiamo riuscire dove tesoro è buono è
cucinato io m
questo è tutto con le mie manine
il ristorante piano eccolo qua in i am
buonissimo ci siamo ragazzi siamo
arrivati al dopo secoli siamo arrivati
al dessert non ce la facevo più
cazzo peso era arrivato al dessert va là
dentro offro direttamente io questore
sera un aspetto magnifica grazie
soprattutto modestamente non è affatto
mare non trovi un borbottio di
approvazione è fatto l'ho conquistata
l'ho conquistata
[Musica]
cenetta romantica una storia
all'ospedale questa ragazzina faccio la
prossima volta è stato non dovete avere
dubbi quando io conquisto delle donne ce
la faccio quindi ragazzi quando avrete
il vostro primo appuntamento quando
avrete un appuntamento guardate questo
video così ritornate sui c'è avete
capito
questi ragazzi se questo tutorial su
come conquistare una ragazza vi è
piaciuto lasciato argomento vi piace
anche a parte di facebook e come non
ridotto la tana definizione se siete
vorresti discreti noi ci divertiamo il
prossimo vinto dalle ragazze